[Musique]
ça fait super plaisir parce que on boxe
à la maison donc déjà on est chez nous
sur nos terres nos proches vont pouvoir
venir nous voir nous donner de la force
nous supporter donc donc ça fait super
plaisir pareil ça fait toujours plaisir
on BO chez nous il y aura nos proches
mais c'est aussi là qu'on doit prouver
c'est aussi là qu'on va un peu plus
avoir à pression mais il y a pas de
souci on saura la
[Musique]
gérer pour l'instant je la ressens pas
peut-être qu'elle devrait être là pour
l'instant je la ressens pas tant que ça
on verra le jour J si elle monte mais en
tout cas j'espère qu'on saura en faire
de bonnes choses moi non plus je ressens
pas trop de pression pour le moment me
connaissant je pense que j'aurais pas
forcément de pression le jourg non plus
par rapport au fait qu'on soit des têtes
d'affiche d'ailleurs il en manque un
nassimam mitouche qui est notre camarade
et et notre ami et qui boxe mais qui
pouvait pas être là ce soir donc on est
trois têtes d'affiche par rapport à ça
non j'ai j'ai pas forcément de pression
et je pense pas en ressentir par rapport
à ce point là en tout cas le jour
J venez nombreux venez nous donner de la
force parce que on va faire le spectacle
euh en tout cas on va vous faire des des
gros combats des beaux combats on va
tout faire pour et en plus avec la
victoire ça serait la suruse sur le
gâteau mais c'est pour ça qu'on
s'entraîner et et puis ça va le faire
venez nombreux ramenez tout le monde ça
va être une super soirée il y aura pas
que nous il y aura aussi des boxeurs
amateurs de tous niveaux il y aura des
débutants des novices des élites donc ça
va être une super soirée box venez
nombreux ça va être
[Musique]
cool